hello good afternoon i'm alice kaplan
director of the whitney humanities
center thank you to the department of
french for joining the whitney as a
co-sponsor of juliet chelbourye's medea
a manifesto
juliette chamberlie is the director of
the center for pre-modern studies and a
professor of french at the university of
minnesota
a comparativist she's published on the
materiality and politics of women's
writing in early modern france tragedy
violence and visual culture
her most recent book interrogates these
concepts at their core
in the wake of medea tragedy and the
arts of destruction in neoclassical
france is at the heart of her talk today
i want to mention to her previous book
the place of exile leisure literature
and the limits of absolutism
here she's concerned with writers who
are not considered explicitly political
banished noble women novelists and poor
refugees who sought out a space for
writing and living beyond louis xiv's
absolutist reach
in both of these books juliet explores
what she calls the lost opportunities of
the early modern period concepts themes
ideas that did not become part of our
modernity
she asks questions that challenge many
commonplaces that look at what has been
overlooked that revolutionize our point
of view on concepts we think we know the
political for example
through her original and powerful
readings julia cherbourg
shows that figures of the early modern
period are essential to our own thought
and at the same time she underscores
their otherness so that we not project
our own categories onto them
before we welcome juliet please note
that you'll be back with us this coming
monday
february 21st at 4 30
as part of the uprooting medea
presentation featuring visiting artist
chevek shaw who will discuss his
production of euripides greek tragedy
with an all multicultural cast and crew
shiv will be in conversation with juliet
along with yale faculty christina krauss
in classics and eric glover in the
school of drama and we're putting a
registration link
in the chat
after juliet's talk we'll have a few
minutes for questions from the audience
so please put your questions in the q
and a panel and feel free to submit your
questions at any time during the talk
juliette welcome to the virtual french
department and whitney humanities center
uh let's get started
alice thank you so much for that uh warm
introduction um and uh to the invitation
from the whitney humanities center
i also heartily thank you santa and your
colleagues in the french department
um while it is really unfortunate for me
that i am not in new haven today this
virtual encounter
recalls to me times really not that long
ago
of mobility configurality and shared
intellectual pro
projects in fact my last professional uh
trip weeks before the pandemic hit
involved work with professor maurice
samuels my last international conference
was in fribourg organized by professor
christopher
and so in so many ways this talk marks
for me anyway
a taking backup of conversations were
stalled
there's one intellectual exchange which
not even a global calamity could stop
and that is the one i've had with
associate director of the whitney
humanities center diane brown and for
her contributions realizing this event i
am deeply grateful but for her
generosity grace and unending smarts
that have informed my work for nearly
two decades i'm really indebted so it's
a real pleasure to be with you with you
with all of you here today
i hope you can see my screen uh the
images are pretty key to this talk
there is a type of news photo that has
haunted me perhaps you too
for about the past five six years
this one might be the most amazing
example but there are many iterations of
this composition and the confrontation
it records
they capture events all over from chile
in 2016 to moscow in 2019 to my adopted
city of minneapolis from just two
summers ago and again this past summer
there are other more bureaucratic
versions of this
they represent a type that of a girl or
young woman standing up to institutional
power in north america and elsewhere
especially the global south often a
black or brown girl so often a young
woman not from a dominating class
we have been taken
by surprise for a long time by the
reality of girl power
and i as an ideal
of political constant contestation but
also of gendered resiliency as we can
see in the astonishing assertion that
females are strong as hell to quote the
title sequence from netflix's
unbreakable kimmy schmidt a show which
when you think about it explores how
ptsd
from 15 years of kidnapping brainwashing
misogyny and abuse can help a young
woman from the midwest make it in new
york
i do understand why we want heroes ideal
people of action what makes these people
particularly heroic generally we don't
know or ask what happens after these
photos it's the stance of defiance
itself that we admire i can't help but
come back to this one of aisha evans
which displays the contradictions of an
encounter between the older seemingly
older versus the younger the overly
weaponized powerful and protected versus
the unarmed and vulnerable
the many versus the singular
it is the stillness and strength that
resilient status statuesque position
here of aichi evans against the
seemingly
choreographed dance of power it is that
which i call the antigone effect
and tiffany has been the darling of
political theory since arguably the 18th
century she is fitting to our story of
modernity an icon of political hope even
as she embodies tragic failure from her
obstinate and fearless conviction that
she must do right by her rebel brother's
corpse and bury it in the face of a
royal interdiction through her
self-generated peerlessness as she
refuses accomplices or partners
especially her truth-telling in the
king's face
yes antigone says to creon i did it i am
guilty and finally most poignantly
poignantly to her lament about her
foreclosed future before she is taken
away to be walled up where she is found
having hanged herself
antigone is constituted as a paragon of
the individual whose allegiances to her
particular familial sacred duties compel
her to test the state's power and deny
its hegemony
there's something surely here about the
pure potential of youth to be sure if
you do attempt to do an internet search
of for example old woman resist power or
old women against police or old woman as
icon of resistance you don't find much
if you try really really hard you come
up with this one
note that she is walking away my
favorite part of this is actually the
handbag
but it can't all be about use
the antigone effect i refer to owes its
enduring appeal it seems rather to a
complex of features to try another tack
of that effect and with a nod to the
central subject of my remarks today a
search for an analogous medea effect
yields very different results
this is uh peter ward's uh 2009 book
is
asserts that life on earth
tends towards simplicity not complex
complexity so involves fundamentally
self-destruction media is also the name
of a gene and a fruit fly and as an
acronym it's also the name of an effect
of another gene which has both the toxin
and its antidote so those of you
familiar with medea's story know why
these results concern the fundament
fundamental act of a life giver taking
life
euripides made her famous for having
killed her children but a full
trans-historical consideration of medea
must however include how she also
betrays her father and kingdom hacks her
brothers into pieces causes the death of
her husband's uncle at the hands of his
own daughters
destroys a city having caused the poison
burning deaths of its king and princess
despite
and maybe because of all the these
gruesome actions i am interested
in what is to be gained by offering
medea the same attention we have
lavished on antigone
um
if you came to this talk from the
schwartzman center i i shall say uh from
the advertisement i shall say that you
may be a little disappointed because i
am certainly not here to promote media
as a salutory icon of positive action
but i am deeply interested her in this
figure as a political figure and a
figure of politics
um
and what follows comes from my most
recent book
which treats the specific case of
violence in the 17th century through the
lens of what i call medean violence and
i'll come to an example from that book
in a little bit but today i want to
discuss how antigone is conceived of in
our political imagination first
and then i will return to medea
that
icon of horrorism as philosopher adriana
verrero has called her and why i think
she might be a more important model for
a future politics
okay so antigone and medea have one
major aspect in common each contests the
authority of the state at the time of
its formation this is true in nearly um
every version oh here is my book
i think we can move on from there though
this this contestation of the state at
its formation is is true in nearly every
version and here are two of my favorites
um
of course the details of this
contestation and the warrants each makes
for her sense of justice differ almost
diametrically antigone is a virgin who
grieves contests and dies
medea is a mother who travels kills and
lives on
antigone wishes to honor her brother
with a burial medea chops her brother
abseitus into bits to delay her father's
pursuit compelling him to recover the
pieces for for burial
antigone laments her father's curse
whereas medea carries with her the
knowledge bequeathed to her through her
house which includes not just the sun
but masters of the occults cersei and
hecate
well for example this is judith butler's
argument about promiscuous obedience
antigone challenges a certain kind of
family
revealing the origins of
kingship and kinship as both arbitrary
medea underscores precisely the opposite
logic
the steadfast power of family whether
chosen
jason or imposed for children
following this logic media traces the
promise not of origins but of the
ambiguity of the future
it is crucial that no matter what
destruction medea wreaks she flies off
alive she's never killed
to live on and perhaps then to return so
while antigone stands for a future
interrupted to borrow from bonnie hanug
medea is an exemplar at once of an
archaism a kind of premodernity we
cannot overcome and a future absolutely
guaranteed to arrive but whose
consequences we cannot foretell
so
antigone
exercising her private familial and
sacred task of burying the dead against
the emergent ordering of the force of
the city
this young and unmarried childless
daughter of oedipus has come to
represent that force of domesticity the
right of privacy and the family against
the overreaching state the perils and
potential of individual resistance and
we shouldn't forget the special kind of
powerless power of women in the modern
state which has so often been a test
case for the individual inalienable
right to self-determination
but
has it been effective to assign a young
aristocratic apparently gendered female
all our hopes
it seems that antiquity has become in
our contemporary time less a model of
political action and more one of our
inability to marshal a clear and
enduring vision of what both the
morality and the politics of resistance
should look like today
sophocles play has furnished us with the
grounds for imagining the individual
political subject obeying laws that are
higher older and broader than those of
the state even at that individual's
peril antigone performs this function as
early as the 18th century
uh consistent with european europe's
rumblings against monarchism and towards
liberal democracy luis de joco the
encyclopedias most prolific contributor
and an expert on legal
matters and jurisprudence even gives
antiquity in the the last word in his
article on the political subject
refuting hobbs's argument about loyal
subjects working as instruments of the
sovereign and therefore bearing no
responsibility for the justice of their
actions
jokul cites the tragedy's most off-sided
and famous scene the stykomatia standoff
between antigone and creon
and he ends his article with this so he
gives antigone the last word so from the
mid 18th century on it is this duologue
antigone's challenge too and refutation
of creon's authority over her private
sacred duties which has become a
touchstone
for hegel lacan urigirai judith butler
and again
to a certain extent bonnie hanik
as a scholar of performance in theater i
find this move extracting antigone from
the network of relations and
interactions which constitute her and
her community within the play
reductive
our ideal antigone has become an
antigone who defies
and contests whereas in sophocles play
she is also an antiquity who primarily
takes action by burying her brother that
is to say the tragedy even when driven
by song and declination as the art was
for sophocles in the fifth century
before the common era
is not just about its words it is also
about the deeply material relations and
physical gestures that bind us tragedy
is by design and in performance neither
monologic nor based on soliloquy not a
medium of icons or figures but one in
which it is precisely the relations
among characters or the tensions among
individual and collectible collective
significations that are explored
the tragedy antigone is after all a play
about people burying people the initial
tension in the play comes from a debate
about who buried a corpse and whether
one should bury a corpse
the plummeting shock at the end of the
play when antigone's own body causes an
avalanche of other deaths her beloved
heymon who's also creon's son kills
himself heyman's mother the queen then
kills her herself which signals the
fragility of creon's own family and
therefore of the state
this is an account of action after
action the best model for the tragedy
antigone is not the fight of words such
as those between creon and antigone but
the consequences of individual actions
on a community
well some have bemoaned what they call
the necropolitics of the tragedy
antigone
um sorry of the tragedy antigone what
makes me most nervous about its eponym
antigone the character is rather two
other aspects she's come to inhabit
first
i am wary of the ways we find antigone
hopeful despite her death despite the
death she brings
not only do i think this is a confusion
of potential with efficacity it also
puts the burden of future change on
individuals as if the underlying
structures the paulus in which she
debates and maneuvers
to borrow from bonnie hanik again has
always been constituted as such and
could never be anything but
my last complaint is this how is it
possible that antigone meets creon one
on one it is astonishing that she might
do so because she's young because she's
defiant because she seems honest
rigorous uncompromising
but it's because she is crayon's future
daughter-in-law because she is his niece
because she is a member of the house of
thieves because she is aristocratic that
she may stand to contest crown's law and
that she may bury her brother and that
she may marry or even forsake haman
antigone is of the paulus and she is of
the family and it is by virtue of these
ancient rights these innate entitlements
that she can sacrificing herself
destabilize the city this points again
to my discomfort with our appreciation
of all those media images of mostly of
women of color standing strong in their
resiliency
these are not images of how power really
works these are images many can
appreciate without suffering the
consequences either personally or
structurally what then
if our notion
of the political subject did not depart
from a an aristocratic youthful subject
who is of the reigning house
might we need to more radically withdraw
redraw our political family tree by
considering the vagaries of geography
conquest inheritance and affiliation
to do so might compel us to reconsider
who and whose stories constitute the
house of thieves and who has been
include excluded from the polis as a
feature of its constitution
what if we contended with the very
conditions that the tragedy antigone
lies after all
that tragedy starts in the aftermath of
war and finishes with regret for a death
not spared and bodies strewn all about
what if the story of politics included
the statelessness that war brings home
the persistence of revenge the state's
monopoly of force and the problem of
women who do not die but rather kill
or to put it better who kill and yet do
not die in some
the question of the role of violence in
the formation and maintenance of society
appropriate
to her final entombment antiquity's name
means as ann carson reminds us against
birth or
instead of being born
we might hope that medea's name might
mean against the mother or instead of
childbearing since she has been so
intimately associated with mothers who
are selfish and who kill their
offsprings or otherwise eat life and
while antigone's final words are a
lament about never marrying or having
children medea's major lament
decries the pain of childbirth and
contrasts it with the trivial wounds of
war
media's name
means rather intelligent planner or
contriver
it derives from the indo-european root
med which emil benevista defines as to
take authoritatively those measures
which are appropriate
the first syllable of medea shares the
same root as meditate or medicine
media's careful deployment of knowledge
names the same authoritative care as
that informing then deep study or
healing this is why she is so often
portrayed as a witch
this ambiguity might explain why the
most common visual depiction of her in
pre-modern iconography is the
rejuvenation of asan jason's father
or
is it that of medea killing jason's
usurping uncle peleus the gestures are
similar enough to give one cause and to
make explicit the connection between
healing and killing you could hear hear
echoes of jacques
pharmacon as the medium for language's
undecidability so the pharmacist the
wizard the magician pioneer always
encounters its homophone pharmacos that
exile sacrifice scapegoat sent out of
the city
and ritually killed as a purification
and as derrida says a remedy
for the paulus
medea is both at once she is exiled from
her own land of cultures so a foreigner
in corinth she will also fly away from
corinth and be a foreigner wherever she
goes
she has knowledge that is deemed
unnatural to the greeks because it is
foreign and potent her estranged
position
is geopolitical and epistemological in
medea's actions the knowledge of healing
and killing are linked as are
magician and exile
two likenesses
of medea speak volumes about this
confluence of knowledge and exile
they're both on roman sarcophagi from
the mid to late second century both show
medea depicted as herbalist or arsonist
connecting the science of knowing and
making with the elemental reality of
combustion and distribution
each depicts the story of jason and
nadia from the theft of the golden
fleece to the death of the children and
the story is told um
on three or four sides i'm forgetting
now but it it it it it it uh follows uh
the the sides of the sarcophagus
each um
and you can see right in the middle of
this one you can see an amalgam of both
of these crimes the theft of the fleece
and the death of the children
with the death of creoza which i'll
point out using my cursor which i hope
you can see right in the middle the
death of creoza after having donned a
poisoned robe gifted by medea for her
wedding
this first one is at the basel museum of
antiquities you can see on the left the
children bringing the robe
uh to the bride crazer who will be
marrying jason
um
you can see on the right medea
in her chariot flying away with a child
slung over her shoulders
and the other one is in there too
at the center crazy as if in movement
is as if in movement her own hand
stretched out in front of her she's
running away from the gown that clings
to and will kill her her father cries
out in back of her and underneath her
left knee is a box
or a stool ordained with
tragic masks even more discreetly behind
the two children to her right
there is another box hardly visible in
this image but art historians of rome
confirm
it is a meta name for the absent medea
it is the case in which she keeps her
herbs
the second sarcophagus now at berlin's
new museum of antiquities is sparser
than vessels so we're even more
immediately drawn to the crayon cray as
a couple who despite the available space
this sarcophagus is much less populated
than the other one despite that
available space are even closer together
here his curly beard
nearly touching her flowing locks the
power of medea is expressed not by such
accessories as boxes but through the
metamorphosis of creos's hair that
symbol of virginity and often as it
flows before marriage and sharing youth
um into um
sorry a symbol of femininity and often
before shearing in marriage the symbol
of youth and virginity and you can see
that creosote is turning into flames
part of the here's a close-up
part of it reaches skyward touching the
frame as does creo's hand
made media's actions whether she's
depicted as an herbalist or an arsonist
connect the science of knowing and
making with the elemental reality of
combustion and disgust and destruction
i
have wondered a lot about why i continue
to think alongside a figure of such
destruction and calculated harm
it comes back to the now classic
analysis offered by bruno latour
in the early 1990s regarding what he
calls the modern constitution that
agreement made to distinguish absolutely
between nature and society between
humans and non-humans media thematizes a
violation of this modern constitutional
perhaps she is simply as i argue in the
book always pre-modern
her very old and foreign knowledge
inherited from the sun is what confirms
her as an interloper in the greek world
who cannot be assimilated
that reminds us that medea is on the
outside both of a latourian constitution
and that of the police
media is doubly foreign she comes from
another place but she also imports and
mobilizes another way of ordering the
world this is what i have come to think
of as epistemological alternative when
what and how one knows contravenes the
laws of nature and the polis such as the
locals have established them
with epistemological alterity there is
no assimilation
a quick example from the many i might
offer from the theater of 17th century
france that most classic of centuries
according to
to traditional canon and periodization
the apogee of absolutism where order
reigned so supreme that even tragedy
eventually was disciplined to within
within an inch of its aesthetic life as
it were strict conventions came to
prohibit any display of passion on the
tragic stage as a matter of decency
thus when piacone oversees the
publication of his complete works in
1660 each play is accompanied not by a
representation of a scene that was acted
on stage but ones that were of such
violence that they were recounted and
described uh but not actually played out
so here on the left from
the battle scene between the horuses and
the curiosis exemplifies this editorial
strategy it's reported three times in
the play
as if happening
just off stage
the tragedy of mede
on the right is the exception to this
rule this is the final scene where
midday having destroyed the city and
killed her children is riding off in her
chariot and jason is left on the ground
in corinth i could talk a lot about why
cognac and his printers deviated from
this program and printed a scene that is
actually played in the play itself
but instead i want to return to another
image of this same scene
this one is from
1664.
um
it is um
from uh uh another complete edition of
the theater of giacomes
and i'm just going to blow it up a
little bit um
it is um
borrowing from the 1660 edition
composition but certainly not in
technique you maybe you can see that
it's much less capable not as nice
detail not as well printed
this is an unauthorized version of
cornay's work printed and sold in
amsterdam
this is an addition that for centuries
up until decades ago was routinely
admitted from scholarly bio uh
bibliographies of cornea's work since it
was considered a counterfeit
despite
that term being both completely
anachronistic and inaccurate
so 19th and 20th century scholars
perpetuated in some ways the 17th
centuries
uh own borders as if a dutch printer
could not print a french text or he or
if he did so was in a certain way
transgressive or in access let's look
more carefully at some of the other
excesses of this image let me see if i
can
get there jason is standing is still
stage right while further upstage two
bodies remain visible one is on the
ground the forms are indistinct so that
they are not meant uh so who they're
meant to be can only be inferred nedes
is in her dragon drawn chariot although
this one is drawn by someone else what
is remarkably different in this image is
the prominence of destruction we can see
that the clouds bearing the chariot that
appear in both images in the amsterdam
images are clearly clouds
from the burning building and in fact
the destruction in this image is far
more
explicit and let's see if i can get a
close-up there there we go
is not only still shown to be burning
flames escape the palace's orifices
but even a skeleton
peeks out from the fire above the
doorway grinning
perhaps at the witnesses who are
pointing towards standing below pointing
upward whether to it or to midday
the amsterdam image is an apt
symbol for median violence a
non-authorized version created and
circulated just beyond its author's
sphere of uh influence and also outside
of the confines of the monarchy for
which classical tragedy would be set to
work it also figures the scale scope and
quality of median violence and its
legacy in and beyond gomez
much like this amsterdam image for many
critics the violence of this myth is
explained in part by the constitution of
its eponym
the character remains an outsider
unassimilable whether of female power or
of non-european cultures and knowledges
well antigone stands outside inside or
outside of the city
the figure of medea has no warrant to be
wherever it is
here again she is
children in
tow the dragon snake-like body curling
through the chariot's wheel regular
technology is useless for this flight
the snake stimulating catch uh also in
the wheels also reminds me that while
antiquity remains peerless and absolute
in her conviction media has no moral
purity to stand on and so offers no
moral lesson
always a foreigner always carrying with
and carried by its foreign knowledge the
figure of media inserts itself into our
community whether we want it there or
not and while antigone dies alone medea
lives kills and lives on
media's motive
operandi is of cleaving to
and from others a politics of
attachments and detachment which offers
a radical model ordering politics
according to relations among people not
by vesting the individual in its own
license
finally then media indicates the extent
to which our political order liberal
democracy based on self-possessed
individualism is predicated on the
exclusion not just of certain actors but
of certain knowledges
oh i said i would offer you a manifesto
and i think i've only done so in part
the problem is what now i am not
standing
here on a rhetorical rampart urging you
to follow me
medea has i've said several times no
lesson to offer and nor do i i maintain
that liberal democracy celebration of
the peerless individual has led us
astray but if you are waiting for me to
torch this place and then kill my
daughter
you have misread me entirely
rather i've tried to suggest that the
violence of media is in many ways here
to stay because of how we have
constituted both the city and its heroes
media's violence is also that of the
figure's sense of history it is
relational it is embedded i think we
need to seek a politics that
acknowledges it acknowledges that
relational that embedded the fundamental
injustice and untenability of a city
carved out of the included and the
excluded
perhaps also then we need to emancipate
ourselves not just from giving all our
hopes to antigone but also to stop
thinking that we can imagine a world
without any medias or that the violence
we know that exists in the world can and
should be kept away outside over there
in nearly every version of her tale i've
said
media flies away never captured or
eliminated
if we built a politics based on her sure
return and her inevitable inclusion
into our ways of being and knowing what
then would our cities look like
thank you
thank you so much
my goodness i'm kind of i'm reeling
as i contemplate the incredible paradox
of your title
um so i can't really ask you
what this politics of medea would look
like but maybe i can ask you
what we
and it might you might just be repeating
from the brilliant talk but what do we
lose what do we lose when we choose
antigone over medea
oh that's a that's a really wonderful
question i think when we when we when we
choose antigone over
media
i think
i i guess maybe i'm not going to put it
as a choice if i can if i can answer
that question a little differently um
i think what happens when we've chosen
antigone is we've caught ourselves into
a model that says political resistance
um
can takes the
takes the form in some ways of a
sacrifice and
um
it costs the city very little to accept
that as a form of political resistance
right because the political agent has
has bumped themselves off right so no
problem yes yeah yes and and i think
that we
i i showed all those images because i
think it's so wonderful to see those
images of defiance but we're also
trapping people in a bind a bind that
that that women of color often point out
that their strength and their resiliency
is seen as somehow miraculous and and
superhuman um and yet situations don't
change for them and i think it's really
important to um
complement that very famous image from
2016 of aisha evans with the one where
she's being taken away because she does
get arrested um and i think this idea um
um
um
this this idea of medea as a heroine
also puts um an undo the way she's been
constituted because i think this is
important what i'm trying to suggest is
that there's a history in the modern era
about these figures that doesn't belong
to the pre-modern era and
antigone has been constituted in the
modern era as somebody who contests and
debates and i think it diminishes the
fact that she also acts and that all
tragedies
even when they're constituted by words
are also about the dilemmas that our
actions cause us
and and that's that's where i think
medea brings to the fore so i guess i
wouldn't i i i've used antigone as a
straw man of of some kind although i
think that that the problem of antigone
is really important so i hope that i
hope that answers yeah i know that's
very it's very interesting and i can see
why you're resisting the one-on-one
comparison
[Music]
we've got a question here
um
i'm intrigued by your claims about medea
and the steadfast power of family even
as she kills many of them
especially your take that the status of
the family speaks more to the ambiguity
of the future than the power of origins
it's such a common place to think of
family as inextricable from origins
could you say more about this move
connecting medea to an ambiguous future
manifestos seem very future looking so
it seems like a key move
yeah and i did cop to the fact that i
made a i might have failed to give you a
manifesto um but but
but and that question is actually really
really complicated so maybe i'll take
that first part um the claim about medea
and the steadfast power of family even
if she kills many of them
so one of the things i think that we
um perhaps
don't don't don't appreciate as much um
let me answer this in a different way i
was just about to dig myself into a
terrible hole um
so medea
i i will take an example of one of my
famous my my my most favorite versions
of media which is the pier palo pasolini
version where when media kills her
children she sings them a lullaby
puts them to bed
and then kills them with a knife
and the scene is a scene of immense care
of immense tenderness one doesn't quite
see regret in her face um and if you
haven't seen this movie it's a really
extraordinary movie um
um
and and so medea my claim about medea is
that medea is very attuned to those
relations and uses them the word i use
in the book is cleaving cleaving two and
cleaving from she knows how to make
people join who maybe should not be
stuck together so creon and krios stick
together through the burning robe creon
will eventually perish from that same
poisoned robe and she also cleaves her
own children from herself
um and i what i what i mean to draw
attention to
with that um
that uh analysis is that metea media
pays attention to our networked
relations and of course family is at the
heart of that um uh so
so i think um
that family is inextricable from origins
and i think medeas confirms that but her
uprootedness her foreign status um also
then um brings to light the question of
the chosen family she is
she her
father of her children is jason and he
chooses to marry somebody else so
where what is the status of family
that's that's a problem that's a problem
in the ancient world as well as well as
in the pre-modern world so so these are
the kinds of questions that the medea
myth asks that the antigone myth never
never needs to ask us um and in fact
antigone refuses a relationship with her
sister she refuses complicity with her
sister so it's also about what's
exacerbated and you know what's put
pressure what what the myths put
pressure on and how our inventions of
them exacerbate those pressures
okay
another question
thank you so much for this wonderful
talk so many questions here's one
is there a way to measure the actual
effect effectiveness efficacy
of medea's representations on a given
society for example is there a way to
measure how performances of corn's media
transform the socio-political fabric of
early modern france what kind of
archives or type of evidence or even
method could we use
oh my goodness that's such a hard
question um
well the method i use in my book is to
think about not
media the
the myth and media the myth appears
scattered throughout the 17th century
there's very little antigone
in fact i'm i'm i'm um there's some
antigone but not not not frontally um
whereas medea but the term that i use in
the book is to think about this notion
of a persistence of violence that is um
that that is seems to be a rehearsal of
of the impossibility of violence
evacuation from society so i take median
violence as a as a form of violence that
i think is constitutive of society so
how would i measure the effectiveness of
media's representation of on a given
society well i i don't think i don't
think i i would um i'm not sure that
that's how literary representations work
but but i'll say one thing about this i
i uh american members of the audience
might be familiar with thomas noble's um
really famous uh painting just before
the civil war um call um about uh
depicting a runaway slave margaret
garner who um
was uh captured and killed her two
children so that uh they would not be
returned to slavery and thomas noble
this was a great abolitionist cause in
the united states and thomas garner um
made a painting that was printed and
that was circulated in popular magazines
like harper's and really was a key image
for abolition and he
he titled that painting a modern day
medea
and garner was an abolitionist that was
not
a
uh that was not a shock at her
at her having killed her children at her
infanticide that was an acknowledgement
of the
disgusting moral bond moral conundrum
that she was placed in um so so we can
measure in some ways what medea means in
society
um
but i'm not sure i could put a science
to that in the way that i think the
question is is asking me i need to think
about that a little bit more thank you
so this is a question from my ignorance
of classical theater but is it true you
were showing the crone images where
there's actually violence on the stage
so does medea manage to
unsettle the beyonce of no violence on
stage just because you can't really you
can't do it off stage
um you know i'm going to say she she
doesn't so so media is actually
performed media is the tragedy that
happens before the seed and
lucide is that play that cree that that
generates that whole discussion about
the aseans and out of which
kind of emerges however there is for the
insiders for the 17th century insiders
amongst us i'll just say that what
professor kaplan is referring to is this
huge debate um in uh the early mid 17th
century about what's possible to to
perform on stage and this notion of
uh propriety is one way of translating
that came up and violence on stage is
just unseemly we can't do it and cornay
says do you know what is seemly it's
what the audience wants he really
believes that we should be listening to
what audiences want and not telling them
and in those pamphlet wars that occur
around this other planet there's seed
cornei
prince for the first time his midday
1639 he prints it and so he launches
midday as a firebomb into those debates
um
i do think
that the
outcome of those debates were was a
gradual
normative evacuation
of the passions and violence from the
stage but what replaced it was
incredibly vivid descriptions that are
quite disgusting if you read them
carefully um and and so in some ways
there is this transmutation of
hypothesis of vivid imagery on the 17th
century stage uh that's that's that
that's quite breathtaking so i don't
think that violence ever goes away i
just don't think it's possible yeah i
mean it's one it's a wonderful issue
that goes forth into into modern
literature with
with the whole question of restraint and
you know ellipsis and why you don't see
julian sorelle at the guillotine and
things like that it's wonderful
okay questions are
coming faster and faster here's one
are we reinterpreting medea's story in
the context of the modern era or are we
rediscovering themes that would have
been more obvious to ancient readers
oh
and that is what that means is i don't
know we in the
context yes
so i'll say what i'll say what what i am
what i am doing in part um i think i'm
tracing how this myth has changed in its
apprehension over time so in part i'm
trying to rediscover the ways in which
these
myths have a kind of sedimented
construction so that when we call
somebody today a modern-day medea as we
did andrea yates in the early 2000s
that's the uh woman um who was diagnosed
with i think she was diagnosed with
psychosis in um in texas um and whose
family believed that her most important
duty was to have children so she had
five children um even even though uh her
medical doctor said that that was not a
great choice for her and she drowned
them all in the bathtub um and she um
she was called the modern day medea what
i'm really interested in there is
does that not
seem to imply that medea is pre-modern
or that we are no longer barbaric we no
longer kill our children but people
before killed their children
and yet infanticide is a component a
feature of our society as it has been a
feature of society
in different dimensions and in different
ways per society so that's how i would
say is that we're sort of doing both of
those things and i'm asking you to think
about the ways in which
you
you believe that that pushing violence
out there is the right way to to treat
violence when it always comes back is
there another way to treat it would be
my sort of understanding of how we
should think about that today so you're
you're not giving us a manifesto but you
are saying we can learn a lot from medea
i am yeah i am yeah
i'm sold i'm sold thank you
okay next question fantastic talk
was medea a big deal on stage in other
national contexts in the 17th century
england or spain for example or was it a
particularly french obsession and if so
why
i am so sorry that i am not as well
versed in that question as i wish i were
i do know that there are
uh medias in the italian and there are
medias in spanish and i'm embarrassed to
say that i know very little about
um english
tragedy other than what was given to me
in the new york public school system
um and um i don't know though the the
the the question asks the obsession in
france i don't think france was just
obsessed with it and i think we can
trace what i call a medean violence in
any of these in any culture and that is
to say attempts at eliminating violence
that then
transmute that violence into another
quality to allow that violence to return
and have a certain kind of effect on
society
so i i i'm going to hazard a guess to
that to that um to that uh to that
person that um
that
if the theme of medea is not there we
could trace a medean violence i i i wish
there were
an expert in any of those traditions in
in in attendance who could tell us yeah
that's how i i'm looking q a folks
please write in
maybe you could say a little bit about
these modern medea representations so
you mentioned the fantastic puzzling
and you showed us an image of maria
callis um
how do they express
i mean how do they speak to you those
two figures
so
so i will say that the the uh the sophie
de haas but i'm just going to talk about
the antigone because i've i've been
antigone bashing for for quite a bit
here um but i want to recover so if he
does um antigone from 2019
which does everything i say that
antigone that our use of antigone
doesn't do that the antigone effect
includes the hosts antigone is an
immigrant
this is a quebecois film
she's an immigrant
she is
she is working class
and she takes on an entire system in the
name of her brother um
the the
the hoops are not big that one has to
jump through to imagine
that um and so i'm not saying that a
figure like antigone is not um
recoverable or could not be transformed
what i'm saying is what we usually do
with antigone is something that's very
different by focusing uh mostly on her
contestatory words um
the puzzling movie um
i think is really remarkable because it
also
strives to consider how important
history is and how important knowledge
is so one of the things i've tried to
insist on in this talk is um
[Music]
is that i think that the foreigner is a
foreigner because of what they know and
how their knowledge is scary and potent
and not controllable and puzzling does a
wonderful job of of of putting
those tensions into play in including in
his consideration of how history works
on children and adults and how lessons
are trans transmitted transferred to
generation to generation the other thing
i'll say about pasolini's media if you
haven't seen it you should run and go
see it because it's maria kalas who's
playing medea
and she is silent
the
diva of opera is silent for like 13
minutes the first 13 minutes of the film
you hear her say nothing i can't
remember it's not 13 minutes i can't
remember how long this but for an
incredibly long part of this film she
says absolutely nothing and the film
begins with these a tonal song these
atonal um music that is in such contrast
to who we think we see um the other
thing is is that i think alice was in
her mid-30s so absolutely aged and this
this medea is is offered as this aged
person and
the age of which and i think that that's
really important
um so i think that that's that's quite
quite remarkable i i could i could i
could name a few other really remarkable
medias yeah
okay give us some suggestions
okay um
so i
will say
um
that the deborah warner medea that was
starring fiona shaw is probably one of
the best known contemporary productions
and it is the the acting is sublime
and i think
it's a terrible interpretation
it's a beautiful play it's a beautiful
play i i cried i absolutely loved what
it's a wonderful production
but um in an interview fiona shaw and
deborah warner both said that medina is
a play about divorce
which is very interesting if you read
the medea play it's about you know it's
possible to think about it as a couple
folks splitting up and so they're going
to argue about the kids and
um yeah and that's it but i think that
what that really includes is the
asymmetry in the play between jason and
media and and and warner's play does
does
just think about that but it really
evacuates the political contestation um
right so it becomes like kramer and
kramer
versus kramer right and i don't want to
i don't i i i want to hold how
phenomenal that production was with a
difference i have in its interpretation
um that if you want to see media as a
play about divorce that is a phenomenal
play um and i'm thinking um i'm sort of
blanking i should have um
no no
um there's the
rachel cusk um uh version of it in which
um
uh which is very very controversial um
i think was that at the court theater in
london which is very controversial in
which media doesn't kill her children
they they overdose
and this was seen as an incredible
violence to the uh to the uh euripides
um
and
i do i do think that we should maybe
stop policing our interpretations of of
classical tragedies um because i think
that if there's one thing that is one
thing about classical strategies is that
they are speaking to the problems
the intractable problems of
of
of
of life in this world with other people
um i i think that that is um
one of the most powerful things about
that so a reinvention of any of these
tragedies is always a good thing oh i
particularly
yes always okay i think we have time for
one more question
um let's see i understand why the
killing of children is the episode that
has stuck in our collective minds but
were all her other gruesome means of
violence the burning the herbs the
poison cloak and more
components of the 17th century staged
versions
so i would i would just like to say one
thing that the killing of the children
is
something that that happens in the
ancient greek
version of it and that's why we have it
that's that innovation before that
classical uh classicist scholars tell me
um it is the corinthian women or the
corinthians who kill the children and
blame it on media so part of the the the
tragedy is to make media kill her
children to to concentrate that violence
into one character so i think that
that's really important her other
gruesome means of violence the burning
the herbs the poison cloak and the other
components are very much part of the
17th century staged version and in fact
pierre garnet spends a lot of time
really trying and he says this in his
preface that he really wants to
even out
the guilt even out the burden among the
different characters and in his version
um creoza is this
she's evie she's she's she's she's
materialistic she's grabby she asks for
the code she says you know what i'd
really like i'll spare the children's
lives if you get me her coat
to jason and and so and she asks for it
and media says okay you want my coat i
will give you my quote and i will give
you more um and that i have an argument
in the book about about that that quote
but there's a way in which corner
actually wants to distribute blame he's
he's not interested in um
concentrating all of that into the medea
figure um which i find really
interesting and really telling the um
the violence and the poison coat and the
burning of are all part of most most
myths and one thing i'll say for folks
who are interested in this just one one
little thing is
that um in the pre-modern period there
are two media versions um there's the
medea who
who burns down corinth and kills her her
husband's um new fiancee and burns down
the city rather kills her husband's
fiance and rides off but there's also
the passionate one the one who helps
jason take the golden age and often the
love the love and you see those on
cassone on italian dowry chests you see
jason and the golden fl the golden
fleece jason and media and the golden
police on wedding dowry chests and you
see that in frescoes celebrating
marriages and in the pre-modern period
there's no
contradiction between those two those
two versions of media can be held
simultaneously that comes from avid by
the way though
i think that's a great way to end and
wet our appetite for reading in the wake
of medea tragedy in the arts of
destruction in neoclassical france that
was fantastic thank you very much
thank you all thank you for coming and
thank you so much for this great
opportunity